alors pourquoi je déteste ça pour toi ici
je veux chasser des aventures bonjour est ce
gars le caquetage qu'est-ce qu'un signe de vie là-
bas en ligne
tu es soit en manque de sommeil ou le mal de mer
et après quelques jours il y a des Asiatiques qui se détendent
pourquoi tu le fais  c'est un sentiment que je
ne peux pas décrire vous et cet horizon infini
comment achèteriez-vous juste une vente qui a une
hache vers la Californie que pensez-vous que
je pense que pendant mille miles est fou
je ne vais nulle part sans que tu viennes
avec moi
[  Musique]
[Musique] des
milliers de kilomètres de la terre amènent sur
n'importe quelle trajectoire de vol qui ressemble à une
aiguille nigériane de 1 500 milles carrés dans une
botte de foin Je déchire Spartan non accepté Je suis
un poids mort prends deux mille milles
tiré sur la lune dans la cible si vous
manquez  Hawaï meurt légèrement, je ne peux pas faire
ça, tu peux faire tout ce que tu penses,
installé à l'autre bout du monde, c'est te trouver,
toi